a man accused of murdering a woman was
wearing an ankle monitor from a previous
case
the i-team's vanessa murphy talked with
the defendant and has a closer look at
what police say
they found she's here live in studio
with this exclusive report
denise and brian that first case against
aaron harris involved alleged
sex crimes against children and he was
given electronic monitoring
in the second case seven months later
he's accused of killing his wife
as for why the ankle monitor was linked
to the location of the crime
aaron harris says he has an answer
i'm just driving around looking for my
wife september 24
2020 aaron harris reports his wife is
missing
he claims she texted him with concerns
about a stranger she crossed paths with
while running errands at this point are
you suspecting some kind of foul play
based on the
text messages that you were receiving
from her
yeah i mean and now you're not now
you're not able to make contact
i can't make no contact without the
facetiming they're calling there
just everything metro police detectives
show up at the couple's home near the
las vegas strip
did you guys have a fight today who you
and your wife
the body of candace harris was found in
her suv in a desert area in henderson
two days later aaron harris is arrested
for murder
henderson police say they found evidence
in a second home near lake las vegas
the 43-year-old woman's scrubs she
appeared to be wearing the day she was
killed
cellophane possibly used to strangle her
and gps
information aaron harris was previously
accused of molesting children
while he waited for that case to proceed
he was granted bail and electronic
monitoring
detectives say when harris claimed he
searched for his wife
at multiple locations his gps
coordinates reveal he was lying
when his wife's suv was pulling out of
that lake las vegas home
the gps coordinates reveal he was in her
car
and he was also tracked to the scene
where her body was found
yes i do have a gps on but this gps
only shows you my coordinates the gps is
an
eyewitness while he awaits trial aaron
harris talked with the i-team from jail
did you kill your wife
he claims he found his wife's body but
never mentioned that to two different
911
but at no point in that call did you say
you found her right
no and i did that i was traumatized
claims the allegations of
sex crimes against children aren't true
either
are you a pedophile no man
there's no history of none of this in my
life i know it looks crazy but
the world looks crazy but the facts
always going to stand strong
he says he plans on representing himself
in court
i love my wife i miss my wife you know
and i pray
that she's going to prevail through all
of this
that's my wife how will she prevail
though
we're gonna find out who killed my wife
we've learned that candice harris was
also a defendant in that initial case
for allegedly failing to protect the
victims involved
as for this murder case a detective
testified in front of the grand jury
that there was a third vehicle at that
home near the
near lake las vegas so in addition to
the trucks belonging to
aaron and candace harris there was a
third silver sedan
a possible accomplice was mentioned we
reached out to henderson police to find
out whether
that individual was arrested and they
declined
to answer